we're asked to simplify this huge long
expression here X to the third plus
three X minus six that's in parentheses
plus negative two x squared plus X minus
2 and then minus the quantity 3x minus
four so a good place to start will just
rewrite this and see if we can eliminate
the prep the parentheses in this step so
we'll just start at the beginning we
have the X to the third right over there
so X to the third and then plus three X
I'll do that in pink plus three X plus
three X and then we have a minus six
minus six now we don't have to put the
parentheses around there that those
don't really change anything plus and we
don't have to even write these prevent
anything with these parentheses we can
eliminate them just because there's a
positive sign out here we don't have to
distribute anything distributing a
positive sign doesn't do anything these
numbers so then plus we have a negative
two x squared so this term right here is
negative two x squared or minus x
squared and then we have a plus X we
have a plus X plus X then we have a
minus two and we have a minus two then
we have a negative sign times this hold
expression so we're going to distribute
the negative sign so it's a positive 3x
but it's being multiplied by negative
one so it's really a negative 3x so
minus 3x minus 3x and then you have a
negative you can imagine this is a
negative one implicitly out here
negative one times negative four that's
a positive 4 so plus four plus four now
we could combine terms of similar degree
of the same degree now first we have an
X to the third term and I think it's the
only third degree term here because we
have X being raised to the third power
let me just rewrite here we have X to
the third and let's look at our x
squared terms looks like we only have
one we only have this term right here so
we have minus 2x squared and then what
about our X terms we have a 3x plus an X
minus a 3x again so that 3x minus the 3x
will cancel out and you're just left
with an X so plus X and then finally our
constant terms negative six minus two
plus four negative six
- - gets us to negative eight plus four
is negative four negative four and we
are done we have simplified the
expression now we just have a four term
polynomial